Salt is everywhere on our planet, but some
animals evolved to live in it while, others
didn't; what happened there?
What caused this split?
Sup salty dogs, thanks for watching DNews,
I'm Trace.
Water is everywhere and is one of the main
reasons life was able to evolve on Earth.
It's pretty great.
Salt is also everywhere.
Salt and water together, make up most of the
water on our planet and it's a major component
of the beginning of life as we know it!
Organisms need salt to survive.
Salt draws water out of cells in process called
osmosis.
Osmosis is the tendency of water to flow across
a membrane to balance salinity.
Essentially, nature wants to make sure there's
a balanced level of salt everywhere.
This is why if you drink saltwater you can
die of dehydration -- the water-salt balance
gets out of whack and water gets pulled out
of your cells.
It's pretty serious.
And yet, as boney fish moved from a salty
sea into freshwater (or sweetwater), they
had to eat salts to maintain that salt-water
balance.
They still do this today, urinating any excess
salt -- sometimes up to a third of their body
weight a day.
We do this too, which is why we crave (and
love) SALT.
But this brings us to the big question -- if
saltwater fish are drinking saltwater constantly,
how do they avoid dehydration due to osmosis?!
Well, there are two answers.
One comes built in.
The gills of some saltwater species, like
the flatfish: turbot, have adapted to carry
more of a special enzyme called "gill Na+/K+
ATPase."
This allows their gills to leach salt from
their bodies back into the ocean.
Without this adaptation they'd die because
of that high salinity.
But, some species of eel, salmon, bass, and
flounder have adaptations that let them move
between fresh and saltwater!
Species which can survive in a variety of
salinities are referred to as euryhaline;
some even actively adapt their gills or their
kidneys…
There are a lot of species osmoregulating
in a lot of different ways.
This is a great example of how evolution solves
a problem along many different paths, something
scientists call convergent evolution!
SO AWESOME.
So, lemme give you a couple examples: anadromous
fish, are born in freshwater and live there
for months before they make for saltwater.
In Atlantic Salmon, an enzyme called type
2 deiodinase is produced in response to the
longer daylight hours in spring.
Puberty ain't just weird for humans.
This enzyme alters the salmon's gills, initiating
osmoregulation so they can safely swim into
salty water!
This is reversed when they return to rivers
and streams to breed and start the process
with thier own lil' salmons.
And a 2013 study in Molecular & Cellular Proteomics,
detailed how a DIFFERENT adaptation evolved
in tilapia.
When placed into salted water gradually, the
researchers found tilapia gills adapted, producing
a specialized protein called NDRG1.
This let the tilapia survive in a saline environment
-- as long as they had time to slowly adapt.
A lot fish evolution has happened in the last
400 million years.
Fish have spread into pretty much every water-based
environment on the planet.
After the Great Dying 250 million years ago
which wiped out 95 percent of all marine species,
evolution had to figure out how to osmoregulate
again.
Through an assortment of convergent evolutionary
adaptations FRESHWATER fish repopulated the
oceans -- learning to deal with the super-salty
water.
Eventually, they made it to land as well,
when a fish named eusthenopteron evolved into
amphibians -- and tetrapods -- like you and
me!
Without salt, and being able to regulate it,
life as we know it wouldn't exist.
Evolution is
the best.